my wife and I suffered three weeks of
turmoil which including losing which
included losing a child how do I ask the
right that moment when we pick up
ourselves pick ourselves up and keep
moving forward because I am done sulking
and we need to move forward basically
how to push through so I mean obviously
that's heartbreaking and I can't even
imagine the pain that you are going
through in this situation and it's one
of those things we've talked about this
before
the fact is we don't really have a
cultural protocol for what to do when we
lose a loved one and you have to
basically make up that protocol I can't
I can't dictate what that protocol is
going to be for you but I can tell you
some things from my perspective from
some of the things that I've been
through I can tell you my perspective on
loss and the first thing is that you
already know it's going to be wretched
and you're not going to escape it and
that pain and this is this is something
that I've identified the pain that's
going to come it's going to come in
waves and at first you won't even notice
that there waves because all the waves
are going to be so close together and
they're gonna be so continual and
they're gonna be right on top of each
other and the pain and the sadness is
gonna feel like it's so heavy it's gonna
feel like you are
drowning in sorrow like you're not gonna
get any air and like you're not gonna be
able to escape that sadness that's what
the waves feel like at first and then at
some point there's gonna be a little
break just a little break just a little
bit of light in the darkness something
is gonna make you smile something is
gonna make you laugh something's gonna
just show you just a little bit of light
and I don't know when that's gonna
happen and then you're gonna see that
little that little smile that little
light and then the another wave of pain
is gonna come back again and it's gonna
be strong and you won't have any control
over it you won't be able to say no no
I'm I'm in the right now I'm smiling
right now I'm not gonna I'm not gonna go
back there no you're not gonna be able
control it that's scary it's scary
because we we get used to as adults hey
we can kind of get control of things and
all of a sudden you're not gonna have
control it's gonna hit you and you're
gonna feel it but again like a wave like
a wave in the ocean that is gonna
eventually subside again and you'll see
a little bit of light and you'll get a
little bit of a smile and you'll feel
okay for a second and then guess what
another waves gonna hit you it might not
be as strong as that other way to a wave
and you might not even notice that it's
not as strong but again you can't
control your emotions and you'll find
yourself this is what I'm talking about
factually you're gonna be sitting there
and all of a sudden you're gonna be just
crying uncontrollably that wave is gonna
hit you you're gonna go from normal to
just crying uncontrollably and being sad
that's what's gonna happen
and again you're in your mind you can be
thinking I can't control this isn't it's
a wave and you're you're at the mercy of
this ocean of sorrow but don't let that
scare you don't let that scare you
because I'm telling you that that wave
is going to subside again and this is
gonna go on it's gonna go on and the
waves they will become weaker and what
you need to realize is just because the
waves are becoming weaker this doesn't
mean that you love your child less or
you miss them less or that you aren't
crushed at their passing it just means
that you're starting to be able to deal
with it which is what you're supposed to
do and as the waves get weaker which
they will they'll also appear less
frequently and again that's okay it
doesn't mean that you don't think of
your child all the time it just means
that it's being dealt with and while
this is happening while you when you
can't when you start to when the weather
storm waves start to come a little bit
what you can do is you can row the boat
you can row the boat one and what I mean
by that is start doing something
productive to get your mind moving
forward I don't know how long this is
this this is you know when you feel a
little bit of a break then let's do sit
a few days go by five days go by three
days go by at some point you can't cry
anymore
okay let's do something productive let's
sort out the drawers in the bedroom
let's vacuum let's finish a product
that's do something productive and if
there's something that distracts you
that's fine do it
let let let there be some calm in the
water and also as the as the calm comes
also you're gonna find moments where
it's like you can you can have things
that are gonna bring on the waves and
that's okay to bring on the waves go and
look at the pictures write down the
memories read the letters read the notes
read the emails remember and then
there's that standard service you're
gonna do the memorial you're gonna do
the burial and when that's over let a
little bit more time go by give yourself
another week of washing around of
feeling that sorrow of letting the waves
toss you around in the ocean but after
another week what you do is you go and
you write a letter you write a letter to
your child and you explain to them
explain to them how much they meant to
you explain to them how heartbroken you
are that they are gone and then explain
to them why you are going to carry on
why you are going to keep going with
them in your heart
explain to them why you're not going to
dwell in their loss and explain to them
how in losing them
you have learned without a shred of
doubt how truly precious life is
and that they have taught you the
immeasurable value of your own life and
your wife's life and your family's life
and explain to them that you know that
you know that they loved you and that
you know that they would want more than
anything for you to be happy and
productive and impactful in the world
and explained in that letter what you
will do to make them proud of how you
live your life and then take that letter
and go to their grave and read it to
them
and cry and kiss their soul and tell
them that you'll see them on the other
side and then go live your life and
those waves are still gonna come and
they're still going to be pain and
they're still going to be sorrow but you
go and live your life and live it well
and make them proud